hi everyone I'm Scarlett Johansson I'm
really excited to bring you my new movie
ghost in the shell I play the major and
it's a film that I feel very passionate
about I know you guys are going to be
seeing me a film in its entirety very
soon but until then please take a look
at this five-minute clip please enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this major I'm safe I'm you I'm flawed
by great change and enhance Winton now
there's nothing I can't do nothing
nothing I can know something I can't be
wait listen
[Music]
my four-year-old daughter time it took
her to sing that lullaby so to speak
fluent French an echo box up here and
when scanning due to traffic versus
conserving practicing hotel security
network
[Music]
anyone
got it 43rd floor someone contact
president staff someone's watching him
Todd's mother what is it you wanna come
on I think it's more about what hanker
robotics can do for you seventy-three
percent of this world bulking up to the
80 Cybernet I really want to be left
behind
my people embrace cyber announcements as
do i no one really understands to
individuality identity messing with
humans
gentlemen excuse me I think it's always
six men shot fired okay nine ETA
criminals out major you're not
you
they speak before from your competitor
and now I can report except between your
new teaser agency ah coconuts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't let me go
who sent you please answer me
collaborate with HECO robotics and be
destroyed
I'm watching you
you have to remember someone down there
it wasn't human the known terror and he
killed again he didn't just kill them I
hacked into the right is everywhere and
no more I will find him and then will
kill him
you never talk about your past not
remember the fragment there was an
attack you were dying
we saved you and now you see the others
everything they told you what lie you
had a family
remember that but I was you you are
all you want for me they did not save
your life they stole it
how many were there before me
she was the cook to have a clean brief
i order you determinate
thank you
they created me but they cannot control
me
[Music]
breathe
do you remember anything about the
attack you were in an accident I
shouldn't tell my watch body was damaged
we can save it on your brain survived
hurt who is the major is a good question
and this film is really about a journey
of self-discovery for the character
everyone around me they feel connected
to something
scarlet did bring so much to it she's
really inhabited the role hidden anger
laughs hidden humanity she really became
the major goddess character has an
ability to adapt herself with any
situation we saved you and now you see
the others specific nature I'm going in
this experience has been like nothing
else I've ever had before it's a ride
for sure
[Music]
these Stoli
[Music]
coca-cola long form of a monocot ' oh
she who made the anime oak and visitors
in production to see that world imagine
it's pretty spectacular gay love it is
so bacon from the beginning it's very
true the anime Rupert is really a
visionary
that's very good thanks fella she's
incredible it's great to start from
something that inspires you
as experience has been like nothing else
I've ever had before
so also multiple police department
increases
what I saw was so gentle nothing nothing
I'm not a driver for another girl
thank you whatever happened we created
the universe that people haven't seen
before
[Music]
[Music]
this is major a month
I'm going
[Music]
who are the first of your kind
but you're not invulnerable maybe next
time you can design me better everyone
around me they feel connect something
connected
[Music]
ah he he was dying
who saved you and the other
out of the more tricky
now I have a path
I find out who I was
everything they told you was a lie who
are you
they did not save your life they stole
it
[Music]
you